At this point, adding a new method to the Car class is as easy as modifying one
line of code and then it will automatically be available on the object.
If you're not familiar with the syntax of extend,
you should look up an implementation that's made available in one of the many
open source libraries that build this for you.
But know that it is not a native JavaScript function.
So to keep our example simple, we're going to go back to the old version of
the code that only have one method to add to every Car.
Let's go back to our diagram.
In these most recent edits, we have gone from having a move variable that stored
a function object to instead having a methods variable that stores an object.
And that object has a move property pointing to the same function.
You could say that this is better,
because the methods object is now capable of storing as many
difficult methods as you want to have available on every Car instance.
One problem I'm noticing with this code is that the name methods,
doesn't seem to make it very clear that the methods object is affiliated in
some way with the Car class.
We could easily confuse it as being perhaps a method container for
some other class.
Furthermore, in the current code it's a global variable,
which is something we should avoid.
It'll be nice if the methods object was clearly encapsulated somehow along with
the Car class function,
such that the two of them were bundled up together nice and neat.
But it's just as easy to store an object like this methods object,
as a property of another object as it is to store it in the global variable.
So, let's use the object features of the Car function to make room for
the object that stores these methods.
Instead of using a global variable called methods,
we will instead put a property on the Car function called .methods